ukraine is warning that its troops may
have to pull out of their last pocket of
resistance in the eastern luhansk region
to avoid being surrounded by russian
forces
these satellite images show the
aftermath of the recent bombardments in
eastern ukraine where pro-russia
separatists say they've taken the
strategic railway hub of lehman
russian forces are also advancing from
three directions on the nearby twin
cities of sivero donetsk and lissy
chansk
ukrainian-controlled cities in the
region have come under relentless
bombardment
well u.s president joe biden accused
russian president vladimir putin of
working to eradicate ukrainian identity
putin's brutal brutal war in ukraine
not only is he trying to take over
ukraine he's literally trying to wipe
out the culture and identity of the
ukrainian people
attacking schools nurseries hospitals
museums
with no other purpose
than eliminate a culture
a direct assault
on the fundamental attendance of
rule-based international order
all right well let's go to the ukrainian
capital kyiv where dw correspondent
rebecca ritters is standing by hi
rebecca good to see you now ukraine's
military leadership is saying its forces
may need to retreat from some positions
in the east of the country
what can you tell us about the situation
there now
well the situation in the donbass is
really not going in the way of the
ukrainian side
they've already admitted a couple of
days ago that they've lost the upper
hand in that region that russia is
overpowering them and now as you've been
reporting the mayor of luhansk saying
that ukrainian troops will likely have
to pull out of that area that last
ukrainian stronghold city of sivera
donetsk as the russians are just pushing
forward and advancing and will soon
encircle that city so in order to have
the troops not be encircled as well
they're going to potentially pull back
and shore up defense lines further
behind in ukrainian territory but
president zelinski's been at pains to
say that even if the russians do
overtake this area take over don bass as
is looking likely it's not going to be
forever and the ukrainians will fight
back when they have more weaponry here's
what he had to say in his address last
night
we are protecting our land the way that
our current defense resources allow us
we are doing everything to reinforce it
and we will reinforce it
if the occupiers think that liman and
sivira donetsk will be theirs they are
wrong the donbas will be ukrainian
because it's us it's our essence
even if russia brings destruction and
suffering there we will rebuild every
city and every community
there is no and there will be no real
alternative to our ukrainian flag
so rebecca the ukrainian president
saying he'll reinforce his troops but
does he have enough military equipment
to do that
well the short answer is no pablo i mean
you know president zielinski really
defiant they're really you know showing
words of strength but uh at the end of
the day they just are completely
outnumbered when it comes to heavy
weapons and that's what they've been
saying for weeks in fact in since the
beginning of this conflict this war
they've been calling for more support
from the international community when it
comes to heavy weaponry and they did see
some response from the international
community particularly from the u.s and
they were getting lots of weapons but
they need more they say in order to be
able to push back the russians uh russia
just has so much more when it comes to
you know tanks and artillery and these
huge missiles and stuff that that
ukraine just it's a bit of a david and
goliath battle if you will and you know
president zielenski the foreign minister
here and really the entire ukrainian
side just calling for more weaponry
because they are outnumbered and without
that weaponry they won't be able to hold
the russians back
rebecca what can you tell us about the
civilians that are still holding out in
these towns in the east i mean we
reported yesterday that many of them are
hiding in basements
well that's right i mean the situation
down there for civilians is incredibly
dire i mean everyone has been following
along with mariupol you know knowing
that everyone was living in bunkers and
the similar thing is happening there in
the donbass and this region has been
bombarded for months the civilians there
have been living without electricity and
other utilities for weeks even months
now and they are having to live largely
underground in bomb shelters as the
russians continue to bombard they're now
running out of food medicines and of
course it's it's incredibly difficult
almost impossible now to get
humanitarian aid into those areas a
couple of days ago was still possible
through some roads in ukrainian
territory but those last remaining roads
are just being completely bombarded so
it's too dangerous now to get aid in so
you know the situation there for
civilians on the ground is you know
nothing short of dire they're living day
and night the people that have have
stayed behind or of course some people
have chosen to stay behind but obviously
a lot of people who just weren't able to
get out so people who are disabled or
elderly so the situation for them you
know it it's it just doesn't bear
thinking about
dw correspondent rebecca ritters in kiev
thank you
you